help her by asking the social media
algorithms to stop reinforcing to others
and to her that this is what the world
wants of her and Eugenia
I don't know you I'm not your dietitian
I'm obviously like not your friend I've
never met you but I can identify with a
lot of the things I've heard you say in
the past my voice sounded a lot like
yours and it takes an enormous amount of
Bravery to choose life and choose
recovery and choose to show up for
yourself every day and this place like
this toxic social media space that we
are occupying is not worth your
beautiful life so if you see this please
contact me I would love to extend an
olive branch to help you find the people
who can actually help support you rather
than just feed you to the proverbial
wolves so no strings attached please
message me Eugenia even if it's just to
catch up and chat